[Music]
sometimes the the solution to a
challenge in life isn't cover or
thinking it's to step back and look at
this look at the problem not the
solution and then you'll realize that
you had some hidden assumption or some
assumption that you could relax that you
didn't realize and that will change
everything for example here's a riddle
Marjorie and Margie were born of the
same mother and father on the same day
of the same month at the same hour and
yet they are not twins how is that
possible so these two girls were born at
the same time the same parents but
they're not twins well the answer is
they're triplets
now you could you could start reasoning
you're not going to get there because
you have an assumption implicit
assumption that you're making of a
picture in your mind that's why the
riddle is tough I say Marge Marjorie and
Margie you picturing two girls or two
women once you have that picture in your
mind you're excluding the answer which
is triplets or quadruplets or something
else like that and that's that happens
in life too that sometimes the answer is
easy once you question your assumptions
and that's a key to elastic thinking the
human brain is an idea machine on the
unconscious level a level that you're
not even aware of your brain is
constantly making associations and
coming up with ideas now if all these
ideas just popped into your
consciousness you'd be overwhelmed you
would drown in them you wouldn't be able
to function as some people with certain
mental disorders experienced they if
you're schizophrenic for instance you
might be swamped with so many sensations
and ideas that you can't even connect
with reality most of us do better than
that because we have these things called
cognitive filters in our brain that kill
the ideas that are less conventional or
less likely to be true less connected to
reality and they allow the more ordinary
ideas to come through on the theory in
your brain that those are the ones most
likely to work and in most circumstances
they are the ones that that work but
sometimes they're not and you need that
you need a different idea when you're
looking to think differently you have to
learn how to relax those cognitive
filters when you relax
mine is only when you relax your mind
and you open your mind and you open
yourself that a new idea can pop into
your mind that hey maybe I'd never
thought of this I didn't I didn't
question that so because of that when
you're exercising elastic thinking when
you're trying to get a new idea or to
question an assumption overcome a mental
barrier to adapt to change rather than
applying the same old same old it's
important to keep all distractions away
from you keep anything that would focus
your mind away for instance your cell
phone even if if you're not checking
your cell phone but you know it's on you
might feel it vibrate or you might just
think I wonder what's there that's bad
changing your task multitasking is bad
you're not going to get these really
brilliant ideas if every 10 minutes
you're going to another focus these
things take time so another point is you
have to give yourself the time for me
it's unlimited time if I'm doing physics
or if I'm writing a book and I start at
10 in the morning if I have something to
do at 1 in the afternoon that kills the
whole morning I can't do it I won't even
start I'll just say I can't work today
because I have something to do at 1 now
that seems a little bit extreme but
there's a reason for that I'm not I'm
not as imaginative I'm not as
exploratory with my ideas if I know I
have a deadline because I have the
pressure that I have to solve this
physics problem or write this chapter or
these pages and be done by one I know
that at 1 o'clock I can have to leave
and I'm gonna not like it if I didn't
get anywhere but what I need to be
imaginative is to not worry about not
getting anywhere I need to get rid of
that and relax my mind and they'll go
this idea might be really stupid this
approach might not work but I'm gonna
try it anyway and if it doesn't work
guess what I'm gonna I'm gonna just keep
going with another one I can't do that
if I have to quit at one and I can't do
that if I'm multitasking so that's
really important in in approaching
things from a new point of view is to
have this relaxed approach another
important factor in encouraging an
elastic thinking is to get rid of that
damn fear of failure most people don't
like to be wrong
you probably tend to forget the times
were wrong or not even admit it you
don't like to fail and you certainly
don't want to have someone who's your
boss or your partner look at you and and
criticize you or judge you or
badly of you for failing well let me
tell you the first thing a theoretical
physicist does is get used to failing
get used to being wrong when you're
having a discussion with someone about
some deep problem
you can't inhibit yourself by worrying
if your idea that you spread out is good
or bad or stupid you just say it or if
you have a question you have to ask it
whether it's a stupid question or not
and you soon realize that these things
don't make you look stupid they make you
look smart so self-assured confident
because only a confident person can be
wrong and not care about it right but
what they do even better than that is
they allow new ideas to come to you
because the more you focus on not
wanting to fail the more the filters in
your that exists in your head that are
keeping the good ideas from coming out
will focus and will beat down those bad
I tore those unusual ideas the unusual
ideas are often bad ideas are often
wrong ideas but if you beat them all
down you're not gonna get the the
minority of them that are great ideas
that no one else would have thought of
because all those other people are
conventional thinkers and they're afraid
of failing if scientists have found
through experiments with people solving
problems that people in a very enclosed
space that's brightly lit tend to have
more focus and flipside stronger
cognitive filters so they don't have
these more unusual ideas but they focus
very much more in their logical thinking
if you're in a less well-lit room a
quiet room without external noises a
room with high ceilings you your your
mind can be more unfocused and allow a
broader range of thinking to come into
play another way which I'm not saying I
recommend is through drugs and alcohol
which artists and musicians and people
of various creative pursuits have talked
about four all the way back at least to
the Greeks alcohol inhibits your
cognitive filters and also inhibits your
executive function so your brain also
has a control function which controls
logical rational thought but also guides
your elastic thinking in a way that's
meat seems useful if you relax that too
much you're going to have you're going
to have these ideas but you're not going
to be able to focus them into something
coherent so alcohol can have
that issue marijuana also relaxes your
cognitive filters it has other effects
just like marijuana has secondary
effects just like shouldn't say
secondary but other effects just like
alcohol does for instance it impedes
your working memory so you might be
getting all these ideas you're
forgetting what you're trying to do or
they might be fleeting memories and and
has many other effects on you
ayahuasca as a hallucinogen that some
people have used which has a multitude
of effects and can be very actually very
nasty and a bad experience but it also
acts on the cognitive filter so drugs of
many types can be used to loosen or
relax your cognitive filters but you
have to be careful because they each
have a multitude of other effects if you
if you want to get new ideas and you
want to overcome your mental blocks you
have to free yourself from those
distractions and from other focuses it's
and and relax your mental filters that
will let the ideas through
[Music]